- The rich, meaty, colorful.
Oh the weave it's so
pretty, look at that weave.
Hey, I'm Matthew Francis
a Tasty chef and producer
and here is my family's
recipe for pizza rustica.
You start off with making the dough.
Pizza rustica is a savory pizza pie filled
with eggs, Italian
cheeses, and cured meats.
The way I know it is from
my great grandma Lulu,
who is like the matriarch of my family.
She's a beast, she is a force of nature,
and I think she gets that from her
mother and from her grandmother.
These little, strong
Italian women who just
did not take any (beep).
And, I think they'd be proud to see this
if they didn't critique
me on how I made it.
When I was a little kid,
I didn't know other
people made pizza rustica.
We call it Easter-piz.
I don't know if it's just
because my family's just lame
and we shorten it 'cause
we're lazy, but it's funny.
Look how smooth that is,
that's a perfect texture.
(playful music)
Love me some meat, man.
You get some sweetness from the ham,
spice from the pepperoni,
saltiness from the salami,
and a little bit of funk
from the prosciutto.
Everything balances out together.
See that texture, it's
not too wet, not too dry.
Look how much this dough rose, and, bloop.
Now for my favorite part, I
love kneading pizza dough.
I know many families decide to make
a sweet or savory pie crust for this dish,
but my mother's side has passed down this
pizza dough recipe to make, I think,
the best pizza rustica there is out there.
Don't get bogged down with the specifics,
it's okay if your families
recipe is different than mine,
and that's the beauty of food.
Take what you love from that
dish and make it your own.
My family will always
make pizza rustica on
either Good Friday, or Holy Saturday,
and you have to wait until
Easter Sunday to eat it.
Because, in the olden
days of Italy, meat was a
luxury or people would
be fasting during lent.
And my grandma had to wait
until a special occasion,
like Easter, to have pizza rustica,
which means now we all have to wait.
I know it's unhealthy, but guess what?
That's why you have it just once a year,
because it's so frickin' good.
Enjoy it.
Try your best to get a good looking edge.
I'm not perfect, my mom's
way better at it than I am.
Then grab some egg wash
and give it a little
bit of a brushy brush, and
into the oven she goes.
Every kid in the family
has a separate job to do,
and grandma Lulu, she'll
like have her arms crossed
and she'll like walk across
the kitchen and look over
and be like, "more parsley."
Oh my God, that could not look better.
I left my hometown to
go to culinary school
when I was 18, so for the last four years,
I actually haven't been able
to make this during Easter.
When I cook family recipes,
it makes me feel like they're
in the kitchen with me.
Try pizza rustica, you're
going to appreciate
your loved ones so much more.
This is why I love cooking so much,
because it's about telling
a story through food.
(laughter)
Nailed it, it's great.
Just gonna take this to
go, thank you very much.
- [Voiceover] Oh yes!
(playful music)